♫ ♫
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE MODERNIZED AND WE
ARE REALLY WAY BEHIND SCHEDULE.
WE ARE WAY BEHIND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE ALWAYS LOVE THE WAY FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS.
THEN A NUMBER OF DECADES AGO IT
SLOWED DOWN.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE AND
BIPARTISAN PLAN THAT EVERY
MEMBER OF CONGRESS SHOULD
SUPPORT.
>> A WORD THAT DESCRIBES SO MUCH
PROBABLY ABOUT 80% OF IT, IS
TRUMPED -- TRUMP TOLLS.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS RESPONDING
TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE PITCH.
BERNIE SANDERS, SENATOR FROM
VERMONT SAYING THE TRUMP BUDGET
IS MORALLY BANKRUPT.
SLASHING MEDICAID BY
1.3 TRILLION, CUTTING MEDICARE
BY 554 BILLION AND SLICING FROM
SOCIAL SECURITY AND DISABILITY.
BUDGET HIGHLIGHTS,
INFRASTRUCTURE.
1.5 TRILLION.
NATIONAL DEFENSE, 716 BILLION.
23 BILLION ON BORDER SECURITY.
17 BILLION ON THE OPIOID CRISIS.
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT WHAT IT
DOESN’T DO AN LONG-TERM DEFICIT
AND DEBT CONCERNS.
STEVE HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WEEKLY STANDARD."
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST" AND FORMER
MARYLAND DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN DONNA EDWARDS.
STEVE, THE ROLLOUT.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING IT’S
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK.
DOES IT GO THE DISTANCE?
>> NO, I DON’T TAKE IT DOES.
WE’VE HAD INFRASTRUCTURE WEEKS
BEFORE, HAVEN’T HAD MUCH
SUCCESS.
PART OF IT IS THE WAY THE
PRESIDENT HAS CHOSEN TO TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
PAST.
RATHER THAN EMPHASIZING
DEREGULATION AND GETTING RID OF
PERMITS, WHICH THEY ARE DOING
MORE.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT NECESSARY
STIMULUS AND THE SPENDING
ASPECTS.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO APPEAL TO
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND I
DON’T THINK IT OUGHT TO.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A TOUGH SELL
FOR THE PRESIDENT ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE ALONE.
I CAN’T IMAGINE IT GOES
ANYWHERE.
>> Bret: MOLLY.
>> THE TYPICAL WAYS THAT WE HAND
OUT MONEY TO CORPORATIONS.
IN THE STIMULUS BILL, IT WAS A
LOT OF SHOVEL READY PRODUCTS BUT
DIDN’T DO A LOT TO CHANGE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A POLICY ANALYST HAS DONE GOOD
WORK ON HOW TO DO SMART
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING.
HE TALKS ABOUT COMING UP WITH
PROJECTS THAT HELP REGIONAL OR
NATIONAL INTERESTS AND CAN
ENABLE PRIVATE WEALTH GENERATION
AS OPPOSED TO BEING HANDOUTS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO LEARN ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND HOW MUCH
IT GOES FROM THE NORMAL WAY OF
DOING IT TO THIS BETTER WAY OF
DOING IT BUT IN GENERAL THIS IS
THE BUDGET THAT’S IRRESPONSIBLE
AND HOW IT DOESN’T TAKE THE DEBT
AND DEFICIT PROBLEMS SERIOUSLY.
IT’S DISAPPOINTING.
STAY WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
QUESTION FOR DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE DEMOCRATS SIGN ON.
ON THE ISSUE OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
LISTENING TO CHUCK SCHUMER AND
OTHERS TODAY, IT DOESN’T SEEM
LIKE THEY ARE THAT CLOSE.
>> I THINK THERE’S A REASON FOR
THAT.
TYPICALLY INFRASTRUCTURE UNTIL
RECENTLY HAS BEEN QUITE
BIPARTISAN.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
PROPOSAL, ONE, WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIT OF
$4.5 TRILLION.
THIS IS 1.5 TRILLION.
PRIORITIZES A LOT OF WHAT SHOULD
BE PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER
IT’S TRANSIT OR HIGHWAYS AND
ROADS.
OF COURSE WE KNOW IT HAS TO BE
PAID FOR SO IT CAN PASS BACK.
THE REALITY IS WITH ALL OF THE
TALK OF INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE, 1.5 TRILLION IS
ABOUT THE SAME AS THE TAX BILL.
IT WOULD’VE BEEN BETTER SPENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I’M NOT SURE WHERE IT’S GOING TO
COME FROM AND WE SHOULDN’T BE
PRIVATIZING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROUGH HIM TO THINK DEMOCRATS
HAVE FOUND A NEW LOVE OF TALKING
ABOUT DEFICITS AND DEBT THAT
PERHAPS WAS NOT THERE IN RECENT
YEARS?
THERE’S MORE OF A CONCERN
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THIS REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION THAT SEEMS TO
WANT TO BE SPENDING.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHAT YOU ARE
SPENDING ON.
IF WE WERE SPENDING 1.5 TRILLION
ON INFRASTRUCTURE, HIGHWAYS AND
BRIDGES, ROADS.
THAT PAYS THE ECONOMY BACK
BECAUSE IT DOUBLES UP ON THE
NUMBER OF JOBS YOU CREATE AND IN
TERMS OF MAKING OUR ECONOMY MORE
PRODUCTIVE AND EFFICIENT.
FOR ME, IT’S A QUESTION OF
SPENDING IT IN THE RIGHT KIND OF
WAY.
IF YOU WANTED TO PAY BACK.
TAX DOLLARS BY GIVING PEOPLE
THEIR MONEY BACK.
THE PEOPLE ARE THE ONES WHO
EARNED THE MONEY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
YOU ARE ALLOWING THEM TO RETAIN
MORE OF THE MONEY THEY HAVE
ALREADY EARNED OR IN CASES OF
BUSINESS IS HELPING TO GROW THE
ECONOMY, PROVIDING SOME OF THAT
MONEY BACK TO THEIR WORKERS TO
REINVEST.
THAT IS MONEY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IS GENERATING.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN’T HAVE THE
FIRST RIGHT OF THE MONEY.
>> THAT MAY HAVE BEEN TRUE OF
80% OF THE TAX CUTS HAD GONE TO
ONLY 1% OF THE POPULATION.
GIVING SOMEONE A THOUSAND
DOLLARS DOES NOT MAKE UP FOR
THAT DOLLAR OR TWO THEY SHOULD
HAVE INCREASED IN THEIR
SALARIES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT’S CLEAR THE NATION’S
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FALLING APART.
THE ROADS, BRIDGES, ALL OF IT.
IF REPUBLICANS ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE, WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE PAY
FOR IT.
WHAT ABOUT THE GAS TAX THAT
HASN’T BEEN INCREASED IN 25
YEARS.
WHAT ABOUT MAKING SURE WE INVEST
IN OUR TRANSIT SYSTEMS WHICH ARE
FALLING APART AND AREN’T KEEPING
PACE WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> Bret: MOLLIE, I THINK THE
THOUGHT PROCESS ON THE TAX CUTS
IS THAT THE GROWTH WILL KICK
INTO GEAR.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THEM OF
THAT WITH SOME OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE INVESTING.
ON IF YOU WANT TO GET IT DONE,
HOW TO DECEIVE GET TO THE FINISH
LINE?
THE DEMOCRAT PUSH BACK ON THE
PUSHBACK FROM HIS OWN PARTY.
>> I HOPE THERE IS PUSHBACK FROM
HIS OWN PARTY ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES.
I WORRY THERE WON’T BE.
INCREASED SPENDING IS A TAX
INCREASE, EVENTUALLY.
THE BEST WAY TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE
OF THEIR MONEY IS CUT SPENDING,
NOT INCREASE SPENDING.
AS A LOT OF IRRESPONSIBILITY.
I GET THE FEELING REPUBLICANS
DON’T FEEL THIS IS A BATTLE THEY
CARE ABOUT.
REPUBLICANS LONG CLAIMED THEY
CARED ABOUT THESE THINGS AND
THEY HAVE THE POWER AND THEY ARE
NOT DOING ANYTHING THAT
DEMONSTRATES THEY DO.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP AND SPEAKER RYA
SPEAKER RYAN.
>> WE OWE $18 TRILLION.
WE ARE GOING TO 21 TRILLION IN
ULTIMATELY 24, WHICH IS THE
MAGIC WORD.
24 TRILLION IS THE MAGIC NUMBER.
THAT’S LIKE THE POINT OF NO
RETURN.
WE ARE GOING TO END UP BEING
ANOTHER GREECE AND MAY BE
ANOTHER DETROIT.